Welcome back everyone it's Charlie.
This will be my Full
Mandalorian Season
3 Episode 8 Finale Video.
There are a whole bunch of Easter eggs and
references, so we'll break it all down.
Also helping set up
what's happening during the Ahsoka series.
It's also explain what's happening next.
Like the Mandalorian season
for the Thrawn movie, everything else.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
I will be doing full episode videos
for Ahsoka when it starts really soon.
Care for spoilers for the episode
if you haven't seen it yet,
We'll just start at the beginning.
Work our way through, shot by shot,
talking about Easter eggs and WTF moments,
even though it seemed like
there were some big final moments
for characters like big endings.
I don't think that they're
completely gone.
Mando Bo-Katan and Grogu,
who definitely had the high ground,
but I do think that Moff Gideon
will return.
And so Veronica
and I have the high ground.
The whole title of the episode
was The Return, which is meant to be
a reference to the Mandalorians
finally returning to Mandalore.
The planet is Bo-Katan.
The armor always wanted to do relighting
the Great Forge is a big symbol
for their people retaking the planet,
a reference to the myth a saw returning,
paying off that big rogue Easter egg Grogu
who's speaking to giant animals
like the ring corps.
And it's a reference to Grand
Admiral Thrawn
returning to the regular part
of the galaxy as they teased previously.
This season, the heir to the Empire,
signaling the beginning of a much
larger war between the Remnant Empire,
the New Republic and the Mandalorians.
The restored Mandalorians are there
in the process of restoring their res
as we push into the Ahsoka series,
which is set during the same time
period, is sort of
like the next part of the story.
They're getting ready to film The
Mandalorian season four later this year,
and then obviously eventually
we'll get to the Thrawn movie,
even though they haven't said exactly
which year that's going to be released.
One of the terms we use is,
you know, the war between the New Republic
and the Remnant Empire.
So we're going to see, you know,
you need a conflict
and I'm, you know, just kind of looking
at a lot of the things
that were written over the years
in various expanding universe projects.
It sounds right now like the Thrawn movie
were the Mandalorian characters,
the Ahsoka characters,
the skeleton crew characters,
Any other spin offs
that they might do between now and then?
All crossover and fate.
Grand Admiral Thrawn
won't happen until like the second movie
that Lucasfilm releases.
I believe the first Star Wars movie
that they're going to release in 2025
will be that sequel movie
set 15 years after the rise of Skywalker.
But they haven't completely confirmed
that.
Yeah, that's just the theory right now.
The actual opening scene of the episode
picks up immediately at the end of Episode
seven with Bo-Katan
and the other Mandalorians still escaping
on the ground running from Moff Gideon
Super commandos explode
still in flight with his jetpack
heading into orbit to bring support back
and bring back that crazy assist
with the giant cruiser R.I.P.
to the giant cruiser.
At least they were able to use it
to get rid of Moff Gideon Baze.
She also has to quickly explain
what's been going on
to expose who's been in flight
this whole time.
He didn't
learn about the rest of the secret base
that had been there the whole time.
Like we know you're
heading back to the fleet to get support.
But by the way,
there's been a secret imperial base here
for this whole time since the Great Purge.
So we need to do something
about that, too.
I was a little surprised
to see how quickly Grogu, who saved Mando
using IG 12 body from the Super commandos
like he's clicking the
no button. They use that a couple of times
in the episode with him clicking the
no in the yes.
I wasn't expecting him to save Mando
until Mando had actually been taken
into that debriefing room,
but I think we all assumed
that he was going to be
the one to save Mando.
It was meant to be a big callback
to Mando.
Saving Grogu during season
two in Moff Gideon Prison Cell.
I think the reason they did it this way,
the reason why it happened so quickly,
is just because
the runtime of the episode was so quick.
Like it was actually
a pretty short episode for being a finale.
Mando and Grogu
who have a bit of a bro out moment
where they fist bump and agreed to go
smash the hell out of Moff Gideon.
And it meant like
we need to get rid of them or
they're going to continue being a problem
coming after us at every turn.
And. Hulk Oh,
Smash.
So it's like Grogu agreeing to Hulk Smash,
but using the force on Moff Gideon
the Super commandos in the Pretorian Guard
in Smash them.
He does like he winds up going full
hulk on the Pretorian guard
elsewhere Bo-Katan
the Mandalorians continue their escape,
making it to the surface
with their jetpacks.
As Moff Gideon continues deploying his tie
interceptors, his tie bombers.
He has a pretty sizable force in that
base, even though it didn't seem that big.
Remember during episode seven
he requisitioned way more typewriters,
interceptors, tie bombers.
So his forces were actually meant
to be pretty big
in when the super commando comes to inform
Moff Gideon of the attacks
in that same room
where he met the Shadow Council,
you notice that
the Super Commandos voice is different.
That's just to confirm
that all the super commandos were meant
to be completely different from the force
sensitive dark trooper
clones of Moff Gideon himself,
that he was creating those cloning tanks.
So, like all the super commandos
weren't his clones.
They were completely separate
people underneath
that armor in the clones were meant to be.
Those next generation of dark troopers,
the super dark troopers that he mentioned
with that prototype armor
that he had been wearing himself
the maul, delivering inspired armor
with those helmet spikes.
All the clones would have been wearing
that type of armor.
So had Mando and Grogu
who not destroyed all the clones.
Eventually, they'd have to deal
with an army of clones of Moff Gideon,
who were all for sensitive,
even though the number of clones he had
there weren't that great.
It sounds like eventually he would just
created more and more of them.
One of the interesting things, though,
is that when you see Moff Gideon
looking at the hollow map of Mando
and Grogu,
you see the red tracker
in the green tracker. For the two of them.
I actually wondered if they were going to
answer who that other spy was in.
They were going to say
that he had planted some tracker on Mando
or something like that.
It didn't wind up turning into anything.
So you can let me know in the comments
who you think the other spy was,
because the whole reference in episode
seven, the title
The Spies, but there were multiple spies,
and it sounds like there was supposed
to be one inside the Mandalorians
Maybe they just haven't revealed that yet.
Maybe they're just waiting the season four
or till the Ahsoka series
or some other series
to actually pay that plotline off.
Everybody been wondering
if it was the armor or if it was Axl
Rose or was some other character
The way they played in the episode?
It seems like the armor was not the spy,
like she seems completely genuine.
Exposed actually
seems like he's still genuine.
So as far as we know,
it was something completely different.
They abandoned that plotline
or something else completely was going on.
Mateo Then get some help from our five
to find Moff Gideon Central Command Center
inside his larger base.
His map of the base
made it seem like it was pretty big.
The command center, though,
is that central location
where he was looking at the map
just a second ago and where he had
all those Galaxy wide Zoom call meetings
with the rest of the shadow council.
We see our five has the same type of
thrusters that R2-D2 did in the prequels.
He never used them
in the original trilogy,
so either they've been damaged
by the events of the original trilogy
and never fixed,
or you could just chalk it up to George
Lucas
not having the technology at the time
to film a scene of R2-D2
flying through the air.
They have a couple of funny scenes
with another Imperial Mouse Droid.
Like the Mouse
Droid keeps harassing our five
and he keeps shocking it away, which is
another reference to R2-D2 doing something
using his shocker during the prequels
during the original trilogy.
It just in general the whole scene.
A man to grow goo in R5
sneaking through Moff Gideon.
The Imperial base
is meant to be very reminiscent
of the Death Star scenes in A New Hope,
with each of the groups trying to sneak
around, avoiding Imperial troops.
Like during a New Hope, you have R2-D2,
C-3PO, hacking into the Death
Star to find plans, helping Han
Solo, Leia, Luke Skywalker and Chewbacca.
Thank goodness they hadn't found them.
Where could they be?
How are those commands coming?
The only difference this time is that
they swap in some of the Mandalorian
theme music while it's happening.
Like a chill version of The Mandalorian
theme, Exposed arrives
on the Capitol ships
and the rest of the Mandalorian
is down to the planet
to support in the fighters
using the capital ship as a decoy
for the interceptors in the tie bombers
just so the armor and the fighters can
actually make it to the planet's surface.
Then Mando, R5 and Grogu all tag team,
the gantlet of super commandos in shields
we saw earlier.
This actually plays
kind of like a video game sequence with R5
disabling shields one at a time in Mando
Grogu slowly fighting their way
through each shield,
although it's mostly Mando.
During this scene here,
he even starts using one of the stun pipes
that he takes off.
The Super Commandos
does the same basic weapon technology
that the Pretorian Guard were using that
Moff Gideon was later
using in the same ones
that General Grievous is men
were using in Revenge of the Sith.
You notice
they were enough to pierce past visuals
best for armor,
so they are meant to be pretty strong
and it look like Moff Gideon
version was like a beskar spear combined
with that stun technology,
which is why Bo-Katan couldn't
just slice it in half with the Darksaber
there's a funny scene of the mouse droids
trying to gang up on R5,
but it's just meant to be pure comedy
because they're so ineffectual,
like they're mouse droids.
I thought they were going to have
some surprise, like
maybe they have some secret super weapon
in these tiny little mouse droids,
but no, they're exactly what you thought
they were all the way since Back in
a New Hope, just little tiny mouse droids
that couldn't do anything.
One of them
even just drives right off of the cliff
face without R5 having to push it.
That's how weak they are.
Grego and Mando make their way through
Moff Gideon cloning facility
with all the clones of himself
meant to become those next generation
dark troopers with Grogu
whose force sensitive DNA.
They use this scene for a little bit
of jump scares, a little bit of horror.
I think the idea here is they wanted these
to be kind of a reference
to Snoke in the Empire.
The whole idea was Snoke is that
he was supposed to have been one of many
failed clones of the Emperor
in the Sith Eternal on Exegol
have been trying to clone him for many,
many years, unsuccessfully
because it is implied
they never got Doctor Pershing's data.
As Commander Hux spoke
about with Moff Gideon Project
Necromancer is in place for that.
What has become of Dr.
Pershing and the research you promised us
the first orders Project Necromancer.
Like he said,
Oh, you have all this cloning data,
this new force sensitive being grogu.
You need to give that does
so we can complete project necromancer,
which clearly moff Gideon didn't
want have anything to do with like Moff
Gideon did not want the Emperor
to come back
because he wanted to be in charge
of the Remnant Empire, even though
during this whole scene, great Admiral
Thrawn was their de facto leader.
Look,
they all thought of Grand Admiral Thrawn
as the heir to the Empire,
as the original Thrawn trilogy book says.
But the whole idea here is that Moff
Gideon kept out research that allowed him
to perfect his clones
as he complains about later to himself,
and he never gave it to the other members
of the Shadow Council
before his base was destroyed.
Which is why during the sequel trilogy,
you wind up seeing Snoke
because they weren't able
to get the perfected technology.
They gave Raghu a bit of a jump scare
when one of them
opens his eyes in the tank.
But the way that Moff Gideon explained it
later is they had not open their eyes
like the clones
had not become conscious yet
it was more of an automatic response
by that body in the tank.
So R.I.P.
repeat all those Moff Gideon Force
sensitive super clones.
You can let me know in the comments
if you think that he had another one
hidden secretly somewhere else
and will try to transfer
his consciousness to that
because he's probably like this burnt
charcoal briquette
mannequin Skywalker style.
After this episode.
I think the idea though, in this episode
is they're meant to move past that cloning
storyline, like this
is the end of the Grogan cloning storyline
and what would see any more of these Moff
Gideon clones in the future?
Bo-Katan and her Mandalorian group
continue their escape,
hiding out in the nearby caves
with the group that stayed on the planet,
explaining that there are caves like this
with plant life, with farms
all over the place,
because they slowly been cultivating
new farms, clean water, food hidden
all over the planet in all these different
plants are meant to be the original type
of plant life that grew naturally
on Mandalore before the Mandalorian.
Civil Wars
basically killed all of them off, turning
the surface of their planet desolate.
If you didn't watch the Clone Wars,
if you haven't read
any of the Legends books,
even before the Great Purge
the Planet of Mandalore, like the surface
was completely uninhabitable
after years of civil war,
the Mandalorians themselves
basically just wasted their entire planet,
which is why they all lived in dome cities
during the Clone Wars, when the Empire
bombed the planet during the Great Purge,
they just made things even worse.
It was already pretty bad on their planet.
This is just meant to show in present day
that the planet itself
is habitable right now.
So they have everything they need
for their people
to move back to the planet's surface
right now is meant to tie
in with the whole theme of the episode,
the season of the restoration
of the Mandalorians, then going back
to the old ways that they used to follow.
Like this is the way of the great
Mandalore as they say,
This is the way the whole idea
with their culture
though, is they're going to continue
to rebuild their main cities.
And Dory here, like their capital city,
eventually they'll do this
for the rest of the cities on the planet.
But that's something
that would take generations to complete.
Even with an army of droid labor,
you'd be talking about
rebuilding massive cities,
repopulating an entire planet.
And even though there are bunch
of scattered groups of mandalorians
out there in the galaxy
who will slowly start to rejoin them,
they're still only a fraction
of their former population.
So one bunch of mandalorians need to start
scouring each other and making more baby
mandalorians
as well as taking in more found links
from other races like Roku and even Mando
himself, who was a foundling
and in many, many years,
assuming they survived the events of Grand
Admiral Thrawn into the sequel trilogy,
even by that time,
they'd still only be at a fraction
of their former population.
Then the armor returns
with the Mandalorian reinforcements.
They have a massive jetpack battle
in the air with all the super commandos,
and it's meant to be a good example
of what it looks like
when an army of Mandalorians
are all in battle together.
They kind of did this
during the end of Clone Wars
when they were retaking the planet
from Darth Maul in the Shadow Collective.
They'll probably do another version
of this in live Action
like a big Mandalorian jetpack air battle
once we get to the Thrawn movie too.
Usually that's where they spend
a ton of money for big stuff like this.
Big special effects Mando and Grogu
who then fight Moff Gideon, who confirms
all of our theories about his force
sensitive clones, like his grand plan
to create this giant force
sensitive clone army.
He gets super pissed off at Mando
that he broke all of his action figures
before he had a chance to take them out
of their wrapping and play with them.
It sounds like Moff
Gideon was really, really excited to mass
produce those clones using the force,
like basically commercializing
the use of the force.
The only thing that I never had the whole
idea with Moff Gideon, if you didn't
get this vibe before now, is that he's
meant to have been a Mandalorian fanboy.
Like he's obsessed with Mandalorians
He wasn't board one.
He wasn't part of their people initially.
He was just a normal person
who rose through the ranks of the ISP,
the Imperial Security Bureau.
Those are the people you see
during the Andor series,
where the white uniforms force
and Kramnik.
The person who's building
the Death Star is also part of the ISB.
They're meant to be the information
gathering arm of the Empire,
which is why Moff Gideon
was telling the Shadow Council
that secrets were his stock in trade,
because that's all about what
the ISP does.
At some point
after the events of the original trilogy.
Then he became a mover
during the events of the original trilogy.
But it sounds like when he was still part
of the ISP, like the regular Empire
and they were executing the Great Purge,
he'd been obsessed with the Mandalorians
and it also sounds like he'd
always been obsessed with the force, too.
I don't know if he also knew that Anakin
Skywalker had turned into Darth Vader,
or if the fact that the Emperor himself
was a Sith master.
But it sounds like his interest in
the force just goes back for a long, long
time, like predating the events
of the original trilogy.
It's kind of the same thing with Grant.
Admiral Thrawn, like great Admiral
Thrawn isn't force sensitive himself,
but he is very curious,
very interested in the use of the force.
Not quite as obsessed as Moff Gideon,
though
he's not quite as unhinged as Moff
Gideon was in this episode.
I just did a big video
about why grand Admiral Thrawn is
so interested
in force users like Luke Skywalker.
Grogu, Ahsoka,
Ezra Bridger I'll link
that video down to the description below.
But the whole idea with this Moff
Gideon fight here at the end
is that his next generation beskar
dark trooper armor is meant to give him
a huge power upgrade against Mando.
So even though he himself
isn't that powerful of a person, like he's
not super strong himself, the actual armor
suit acts kind of like a mech.
Like you can hear the servos whirring
when he steps around.
Like it seems like it's really heavy,
so it enables him to soak a lot of damage
and also to throw Mando Bo-Katan around
pretty easily.
It's kind of like IG 12 body giving grogu
all this extra strength.
Even though his new Beskar
armor is meant to be more maul,
delivering inspired like the maul
delivering super commandos like Gar Saxon
with the pointed horns on the helmet.
Just in general,
a lot of moff Gideon's black armor
is meant to be more of a Darth Vader
reference, which is why Jon Karl Esposito
said he made such a big deal
about having a space cape
when he came to the Mandalorian
in season one.
Like, I need to have a cape
just like Darth Vader.
The difference with Darth Vader's armor
is that it was actually Sith tech armor,
like a bit Sith armor,
and most of the suit
was actually medical based tech
designed to help keep him alive
because his body had been damaged
so badly on Mustafar.
That's why he had to spend a large portion
of every day just sitting inside the box
to take some doing
so that he could keep walking around
like that's how much his body hurt.
He was constantly
in a state of pain in the empire,
even specially designed his Sith suit
to help keep him in that state of pain
in order to make him more powerful
in the dark side of the force.
Because the dark side of the force
thrives on that negative emotion.
So the whole idea with Darth Vader
is that the angrier the Emperor
kept him, the more powerful
he would be in the dark side of the force.
It brings new meaning to the idea of
just living this tortured life
like he was literally tortured
every minute of every day.
But during this Mando Moff Gideon Grogu
you fight in the background,
you can still see all the mandalorians
mid battle in the air with their jetpacks.
Fighting the super commandos is actually
a really cool way for them
to use special effects to connect
both the separate battles,
making the whole thing seem like a way
bigger fight like a way bigger war,
as opposed to just cutting back and forth
between both groups fighting.
They started to do this on a movie scale
to like ABC in the movies
are much bigger because they spend
way more money on the special effects.
So once we get to that Thrawn movie,
you'll see more stuff like this
where big battles are happening
all over the screen at the same time
and they just zoom in on different parts
instead of cutting back and forth
the old way.
Then the Pretorian guard step
in, join the fight
obviously
way too much for Mando by himself.
So Grogu just steps in as we all expected.
He's separated
into the Central Command room too,
but I think the joke here is that Grogu,
who isn't trapped in the room with them,
they're trapped in there with him
like full watchmen style
Bo-Katan winds up
saving Mando from Moff Gideon so she can
have her rematch with Moff Gideon
using the Darksaber
in in order to match the Darksaber Moff
Gideon whips out a new type of stun baton.
This seems like a larger version
of the same type of weapon
the Pretorian Guard
are using made of Beskar commandos Beskar
spear with the added stun weapon,
so Bo-Katan catches a slice it in half.
Back in the command room,
the Pretorian guard make pretty quick
work of it Wells body.
They are meant to be pretty badass,
even though Grogu does
smash the hell out of them Hulk style.
The whole idea is that Pretorian guard
themselves
weren't meant to be force sensitive, but
they're meant to be the fiercest fighters
in the entire galaxy.
The Emperor
turns them into his personal Royal Guard,
and they're just still around
now, while they're trying to execute
Project Necromancer
to bring him back to life in a clone.
So even though Grogan winds up killing
the Pretorian guard in this episode,
their group is the same group that we see
later in the timeline.
They're basically trained
in pretty much every martial art.
You could think of, every type of fighting
style they use, every type of weapon.
So they're just meant to be
the most badass fighters
you could possibly think of next
to actual Jedi or Sith.
And it takes Grogu and Mando tag
teaming them to actually take them down
when he starts
throwing them around the force
that's meant to be a callback to him
doing the same thing to Moff Gideon's
regular Stormtroopers during season two
like Hawks Smash Loki would be proud
Moff Gideon is Tyner sisters
and the tie bombers disable the cruisers
so Axos uses it to kamikaze
destroy Moff Gideon Space R.I.P.
to the cruiser was an awesome ship.
Have to steal more imperial capital ships
when they can in the future.
Remember there are several other members
of the Shadow Council,
each with their own imperial fleet,
so there's still tons of imperial capital
ships out there to be stolen.
Big surprise.
MOFF Gideon,
Why is it crushing the Darksaber?
We'll see if Bo-Katan eventually has it
repaired.
Even is a symbol.
They don't really need it anymore.
There are people already following
Bo-Katan They've rallied together.
It's still a very badass lightsaber
weapon, very effective in battle.
So I'm assuming they try to repair it
by the events of the Thrawn movie.
I mean, that's a ways off, so we'll
probably see the Darksaber for a while,
maybe with a little help from Ahsoka
in the Jedi Droid played by David Tennant.
If you didn't see my Ahsoka trailer video,
David Tennant is confirmed to come back
as the voice of that Jedi droid
from the Jedi ship in the Ahsoka series.
He has the schematics of every lightsaber
ever constructed
by the Jedi, going back
many thousands of years like he himself.
The Droid is meant to be over 1000 years
old, so he's way older than Yoda was.
If you were trying to build a lightsaber
or rebuild a repair
a lightsaber, he'd
be the one to actually help you do that.
If you actually needed help.
Hoping that someday Grogu, who also does
construct his own lightsaber.
So maybe the Jedi Droid could help him out
then too.
I believe all the scenes
that we got of him are in a combination
of lothal in present day
and then in Ahsoka ship.
I think he's been flying around inside
a Ahsoka ship staying with her.
Then Mando and Grogu, who returned to help
Bo-Katan tag team Moff Gideon
in ax mode, destroys the rest of his base
while they're fighting him off.
Even Grogu, who helps out
using the force to disable him.
And here's the thing with Moff Gideon's.
And so a lot of questions are theory
is going on here.
They make it seem like he dies in the fire
from the explosion.
I think the idea here, though,
is that because the title of the episode
is The Return,
they also want to make this seem
like a reference
to Anna and Skywalker burning on moves
too far with Mando Grogu
who bo-katan having the high ground
so early Theory Moff Gideon survives.
This is a charcoal briquette
Darth Vader style in a can Skywalker
and will return in the Mandalorian Season
four in the Thrawn movie.
But I still like the theory
that Thrawn is the one to ultimately kill
Moff Gideon for trying to usurp him,
or just because he grows
tired of Moff Gideon.
The same way that Darth Vader
was famous for killing his own
imperial commanders on a whim.
George Lucas has talked
about this whole concept in Star Wars
just in general, the idea that evil
eventually destroys itself.
And even though grand Admiral Thrawn
isn't technically meant
to be evil, he's more of an antagonist.
The way that they portray him.
Like he has noble intentions and just does
horrible stuff in the pursuit of those.
Ultimately, the Remnant Empire will help
do some of the New Republic
in the mandalorians work for them
destroying each other.
And it would be much more poetic
to have Grand Admiral Thrawn
be the one to actually perma kill moff
Gideon for his previous failures.
Like you are useless to us.
We don't need you anymore. So goodbye.
After the battle, there's a short time
jump in the armor continues performing
Ragnar's christening ceremony
like taking the creed from episode one
because during episode one, his Creed
ceremony was interrupted by the crackles,
so he hadn't
officially become a mandalorian yet.
This time
they're able to do it in the living waters
the same way that Din Djarin and Bo-Katan
did during episode two.
All these scenes of The Mandalorian
at the end
are meant to signal this new era
for their people,
a period of restoration for them.
In preparation for Grand Admiral
Thrawn in the larger Remnant Empire
Forces, the other members of the Shadow
Council still out there.
And there are a bunch of them, each
with their own fleets,
which are pretty large.
So like just because Moff Gideon is gone,
this is only the beginning,
even though they don't directly reference
past Vizsla.
Remember, he's Ragnar's father I think.
Then performing his christening ceremony
here, him taking the creed
is also meant to honor his father,
so to speak.
Now he's officially a mandalorian.
You also remember that
this character is also played
by Jimmy Kimmel's real life nephew.
I believe You also notice
in the background of the chamber here,
they've hung the banners
of all the different Mandalorian groups
as well as the banner of their culture,
like the mythos or banner,
which is represents all mandalorians.
The blue banners have Bogota's night owl
symbol on them.
The green banner, I believe,
is meant to be for that new group.
I think the Red banner is meant
to represent the Armor's
children of the watch group.
But the idea behind
all of these banners here
hanging is meant to represent
all the different clans coming together.
They would have hung this way in this room
before the Great Purge.
So they're just kind of putting things
back to the way
they used to be on the planet.
The reason why Bogota's banners,
though, are hanging
the highest is
just because she is their leader.
So it's like the place of prominence
within their culture.
Big surprise, though.
I wasn't expecting this to happen so soon.
Mando brings Grogu
to actually take the creed,
paying off him, becoming Mando's son
and becoming
a Mandalorian formally,
which started way back in season one.
Like this whole arc of him
being Mando's son.
The armor even called him
Mando Son during season one.
I guess he considered it temporary
at the time because he referenced
Grogu, whose biological parents
from Yoda's race in this episode.
I know there's a billion questions
about where Grogu who actually comes from,
who is Grogu who actually Dave Filoni.
Jon Favreau has explained that
Yoda in Seattle were not Grogu's parents,
like his parents were just other members
of their raised.
It's just that their race is so rare
that you don't see members of them born
very often in the galaxy,
even though they had all these
cloning storylines this season.
He's not meant to be a clone of Yoda
either,
like he's
a completely new member of their race.
And when you're talking about Mando
becoming his father, former,
like adopting informally, Bo-Katan also
kind of became a surrogate mother to him
this season, even though they don't
have her actually speak up here.
So she's not formally his mother
or anything like that.
The other interesting technicality
here, too, the armor brings up,
like she's all about the rules, like,
let me pull out this giant list of rules
about actually taking the creed
before we actually do this.
Here is that Grogu?
You can't actually physically
speak the words
and you have to be able to do that
to take the creed.
Even though a couple times
this season it seemed like he was speaking
words in his own native language,
like Yoda's raises language.
There've been a lot of theories
about how he would actually speak.
The way they explain is
that Yoda was the only member of his race
that spoke that backward speech
and he did it that way to honor his own
Jedi master who spoke that way.
But Yatom, for instance,
spoke the basic tongue
just like all the other people, like
Quick on Jinn, all the other Jedi masters,
all the other regular people,
implying that once Grogu eventually
does become able to speak basic language,
he'll speak normally like Mando does.
And the other interesting thing
just talking about the timeline, Grogu
eventually maturing, being able to speak.
They just announced a new Star Wars
sequel movie set 15 years
after the rise of Skywalker.
By that time, Grogu
would be close to the same age Yoda was
when Yoda became a Jedi master,
like close to about 100 years old.
So Grogu would be fully grown and have
long since been able to speak normally.
Like everyone else.
So he could wind up
appearing in that movie.
The full Chad version of Grogu
do that as the armor recognizes Grogu
as Mando's official son,
his new name becomes
din Grogu to the point
not going to use the full name
that many times apologists
continue to call him Grogu.
But every once in a while,
like when he goes back to see the armor,
the armor will refer to him
as doing grogu to the armor.
Some of the mandalorians
are just really formal In that way.
He gets a big upgrade
from becoming a foundling
to the next level in their culture,
becoming an apprentice,
which really means
that more is expected of him.
He'll start going on more missions
and there's the journeys like
the adventures that the armor teases,
like you need to take him on his journeys,
which is basically just taking him
to have a bunch of experiences, adventures
around the galaxy, gaining
experience on the job, so to speak.
The other interesting thing here too,
this is meant to be a bit of a teaser
for Season four and the Thrawn movie.
Like everything that'll happen
with The Mandalorian and Grogu
in the future, separate from this
Mandalorian storyline during season
three of them all coming together
and retaking the planet the armor,
telling him to go off and have adventures,
go have journeys with Grogu
is that the show can move past this
Mandalorian Season three storyline
where you had to keep focusing
on all these of the Mandalorian characters
like Bo-Katan, like the armors group,
like the other Night Owl characters.
There are a lot of complaints
this season that Mando felt kind of like
a side character in Grogu who felt more
like a prop in their own show.
Even though The Mandalorian title
is meant to reference
all the mandalorians on the show.
Like it's not just meant to reference
Mando or just meant to reference Grogu,
but the fact that Grogu who took the creed
in is now a member
of the Mandalorian culture
does pay off the long running theory
that we've had
since the beginning that
eventually the title will be a reference
to Grogu who himself.
But the whole idea now is that
they've separated Goku and Mando from this
larger Mandalorian Mandalore storyline
so that Season four can be more classic.
Like Season one was with the two of them
going on a bounty hunting missions
and not having to go back to this
giant Mandalore storyline.
Every single episode
they have been completely said
what Mandalorian Season four
is going to be about.
They just teased that they're ready
to film it by later this year.
So we think a lot of what happens during
that will depend on what happens
during the Ahsoka series
with great Admiral Thrawn coming back
and what Ahsoka, Ezra Bridger, Sabine Wren,
all those characters are doing,
and while this is happening
with Mando and Grogan in season
four of them going off
on different adventures in season four,
they could say in the background
the armor bo-katan
the other Mandalorians are rebuilding
the planet Mandalore offscreen in Mando
and Grogu will just come back and visit
every once in a while.
Then they pay off the long
running fan theory about Grogu
you speaking to the myths
or through the force
asking you to return to the surface,
even though they don't actually show it
returning to the service,
they just show it waking up.
So there's implied that
Oh yeah, like the myth is or it's back.
We'll see it more in future seasons
because it's so huge
and probably pretty expensive
to do with special effects.
They're also probably saving a lot of
really cool mythos or scenes for that.
Thrawn movie.
Cannot wait to see Grogu
who riding that mythos or like Mando Grogu
Bo-Katan It's big enough
that you can actually put
most of the mandalorians
on the Myth of Swords.
Back then they have a special ceremony
to relight the Great Forge
with the myths or banners
all around the symbol of the restoration.
There are people like the myth.
Esau is the symbol of all Mandalorians.
They have a big for Mandalore cheer,
which is a callback to Star Wars rebels,
where they had a similar type of scene
where Sabine Wren gave
Bo-Katan the Darksaber in the first place
for the first time.
I accept this sword for my sister,
for my clan,
and for all of mandalorian
woman For
not. Oh!
Oh, my God.
Oh, Not only is the great forge,
the symbol, the heart of their culture,
a symbol
for the restoration of their people.
It's also a giant forge that you can use
to make really, really big,
really powerful weapons
armor for giant armies,
which is going to be really important
for fighting.
Grand Admiral Thrawn.
The other idea here too, is that they gain
access to the best scar on the planet,
so they just have all the materials
that they need to rearm their people
and probably their allies to the New
Republic if they start working together.
Mostly. This is about the Mandalorians
right now though.
Speaking of New Republic,
though, a short time jump later,
Mando Grogu, who go back to Delphi base
to Sea Carson, Tiba and his Rangers.
This time there's no cameo from Zeb
that I could see.
Or Deborah Chow.
Rick Farmer Yeah, but Rick Farmer,
you were did direct the episode
and we do get a Dave
Filoni cameo wearing his trademark
hat very prominently to here this time.
Like he's sitting in clear
view of the camera,
just sort of teasing the idea
that the Ahsoka episodes are coming
because he directed and wrote
most of the Ahsoka episodes.
We also get a much better look at the bar.
You notice
they've decorated with the helmets
of Stormtroopers and other droids
that they've killed, has a giant probe
droid head as well in the center Grogu
who notices the IG 11 head?
That's not their IG 11 but they explain
they use that to restore their IG 11
because they've been searching
for the memory circuit all season long
and now they've found it.
The other funny thing about this
grogu is seen at the bar,
even though he's like wolfing down
all of these treats
is that I think this is the closest
we've heard to Grogu who's speaking
actual words even closer than earlier
this season when it sounded like
he tried to say, This is the way we're
grateful for, right?
It's not him could look in the future.
Grogu will try to talk more
and he'll warble more like this.
And it's just him
speaking in his own native tongue
and as part of Grogu's training
as an apprentice, Mando
forms a contract with the New Republic
to become a bounty hunter for them.
On the deal, he's said,
Please don't tell the actual New Republic
bull just keep this between the two of us
because he does need money and it's good
experience for Grogu in training.
And this is just
what they're going to be doing
between now
and the events of Mandalorian season four.
Even though he might have a cameo scene
with Grogu during Ahsoka,
kind of expecting a couple of cameo scenes
during Ahsoka, but between now
and season four, he will just be on
regular bounty hunting missions.
They go back to Navarro
and he presents Greef Karga with a rebuilt
now ideal twin using that head
that they took with the memory circuit
so he can become Greef cargo's new marshal
paying off a couple big storylines
here from episode one,
the storyline about Greef Karga trying
to get Mando to become his new marshal.
In the payoff, Greek Karga
offering him a place to live,
which he accepts this time
a little cabin outside the city
when he says a place
to stay between adventures.
This also is just a reference to him
visiting Navarro periodically,
like all these characters, will still be
part of season for the Thrawn movie,
but they're not gonna spend
every single episode on the planet.
Obviously, it is not like
Mando is retiring or anything like that.
They move into their little cabin Grogu
playing with the frogs in the forest
meant to be a bit of a callback
to his training with Luke Skywalker and
the Jedi Academy on Oz's same basic scene.
R.I.P. to that rug.
Even though he plops it
back in the pond there, he's probably
trying to eat that frog pretty soon,
and they wind
up ending on a traditional Star Wars
style circle transition to credits.
George Lucas
used these types of transitions
during the Star Wars movies all the time.
The whole idea heading into Season four
and the Ahsoka series is that bo-katan
the armor will continue
to rebuild the Mandalore planet
and restore their people more Mandalorians
will start coming out of the woodwork,
flocking to the planet, rejoining them.
Mando and Grogu
will start doing more traditional bounty
hunting like they did in season one.
The Remnant Empire, The Shadow
Council on their side of things
will continue just working
in other parts of the galaxy.
The other sectors that they control
in Grand, Admiral Thrawn will slowly
start to marshal his forces,
which we saw in these Sokka trailer
after returning from the outer rim.
Thus the title of the episode
The Return Many Things are returning
in this episode
and this part of the timeline.
Overall, it was a pretty solid finale.
They wrapped up
a bunch of the big storylines.
Like I said,
I think they're moving completely past
this Grogu cloning storyline,
even though you're still kind of wondering
what happened. Dr.
Pershing Like, did
Ellia Cain wind up killing him?
Obviously, he's still alive.
There's still a couple of big plot
threads that I'll address
when I do a Mandalorian Season
four video in the next day or two.
I was a little surprised
we didn't get a cameo scene
from Ahsoka or Sabine Wren
because Sabine is a Mandalorian.
You think that she'd be interested
in what's happening with The Mandalorian?
So there were a lot of rumors about Boba
Fett maybe having a cameo seen, too.
But the way Dave Filoni said that they
structured the finale is that they didn't
want it to feel like it was being hijacked
just to set up the Ahsoka series.
And they wanted people to be able to watch
both shows, watch The Mandalorian show
and watch it.
So without being forced
to watch every single other show, too,
even though I would definitely recommend
that you check out some of the Star Wars
Rebels episodes before the Ahsoka series
starts later this year.
But don't worry,
I will do a bunch of Bones videos too
after we get through talking
about all the Mandalorian stuff
and setting up Season four.
If there's any other big Easter eggs.
The references that you notice
in the episode
that I didn't talk about in the video
are big plot points that it didn't cover.
Just write them below in the comments and
I will address them in my bonus videos.
So my Mandalorian Season
four video will post next
and then I'll start doing more
Ahsoka videos.
Everyone click here
for that Mandalorian Season four video.
Update the link
as soon as I post that and click here
for all my Ahsoka in my Thrawn videos too.
Thank you so much for watching
everyone. Stay safe.
This is the way.